did you ever wonder how strong the straw
hats will be by the end of the series
which new abilities and power-ups will
they unlock and most importantly what
will their final bounties be well after
thoroughly analyzing each Straw Hat
member for months in finding patterns in
their bounties I finally got answers to
all of these questions for example
Chopper is definitely overdue for a
PowerUp and the one that I'd really like
to see him get is Armament hockey now
don't get me wrong Chopper is already
pretty strong which he proved by doing
surprisingly well against queen during
the raid but if he just learned omor
hockey it would increase the strength of
his physical attacks at least a few
times then there's his devil fruit I
guess you could say that monster point
is already Chopper awaken form which he
has to force out using his special
yellow pills however by the end of the
series I expect Chopper to completely
Master this form to the point that he
can use it for much longer periods of
time without needing his Rumble balls
but at the end of the day let's not
forget the chopper is the doctor of the
crew so the sad reality is that he may
not actually get any decent power ups
until the end of the story also I doubt
Odo will stop with the joke about him
being only the pet of the crew so his
Bounty will be nowhere close to the
other straw hats Chopper's first Bounty
was 50 berries the second one was 100
berries and the one right now is 1,000
berries going by this Chopper's last
Bounty will most likely only be 5,000
berries there are still nine straw hats
left to cover and some of their powers
and bounties will be absolutely crazy
numi the cat burglar numy is always been
considered a part of the weakling Trio
of the straw hats but ever since she got
Zeus she has become a real baller
however despite her newly acquired
Powers there's still a few ways she
could get even stronger first of all she
could eat a devil fruit but this doesn't
really seem likely as her clima already
grants her double fruit like abilities
Armament or conqueror hockey are also a
big no for her but I guess she could
benefit from observation hockey a bit as
it may allow her to throw attacks from a
much greater distance similar to how
Usopp managed to hit that subscribe
button from miles away and dress Rosa or
something like that anyway the coolest
thing by far would be if her climb
attack gets upgraded on Egghead which is
a real real possibility considering Vega
Punk's skills in knowledge I don't know
if you ever noticed but nami's bounties
have always had the number six in them
her first Bounty was 16 million berries
the second one was 66 million berries
and the current one is
366 million berries since Nami doesn't
really care about her Bounty and would
rather keep it as low as possible I
don't think she'll ever reach that 1
billion Mark so we can expect her final
bounty to most likely be around 616
million berries Brooke the soul King
Brook doesn't know hockey right now so
there's definitely a possibility that
he'll learn it in the future since
Brooke is a supporting character if he
does learn hockey eventually it'll most
likely be observation hockey so he can
better support his crew mates in battle
however the most interesting power up
Brooke could get is the Awakening of his
devil fruit the yumy yumy Nomi is
definitely one of the most unique fruits
out there as it can literally bring
users back to life it also has other
cool abilities like allowing Brooke to
separate his soul from his body and
essentially become a ghost so what kind
of abilities would Awakening of this
fruit Grant to Brook well although this
is purely speculation based on other
Awakenings we've seen in the series so
far Brooke may be able to project his
abilities on the world around him for
example he may be able to separate other
people's souls and bodies or maybe even
consume The Souls of other people in
order to temporarily gain their
abilities allthough this sounds really
cool and if Brooke ever held a concert
again he could literally give his
audience an outof the- Body Experience
if you look at Brook's previous bounties
you'll see that Oda the creator of One
Piece loves to pair Brooke with the
numbers three and eight his first Bounty
was 33 million berries his second was 83
million and his current one is 383
million based on this Brook's fourth and
final Bounty will most likely be 838
million berries although this is a
pretty impressive number for Brooke it's
nothing compared to some of the bounties
we'll talk about later Iron Man Frankie
Frankie is already pretty strong no
doubt about it which he proved in wano
when he single-handedly defeated Sasaki
of the Toby Roo but the real question is
how strong can he get Frankie is another
crewmate who doesn't know hockey and due
to him relying mostly on his physical
for string fights I think learning
Armament hockey would be really fitting
for him also just imagine a cyborg
coated in matte black it would look so
badass although Frankie didn't get any
real power up in wano the crew is
currently on Egghead Island and there's
no way Frankie is getting out of there
without an absurd power up who knows Oda
may even ditch his bulky design and give
him something entirely new whatever the
case may be Frankie is one of the
characters who literally has infinite
potential for improvement as he can
always integrate new stronger materials
with his body and add any new weapons he
makes once Luffy becomes the pirate king
in the story ends I'd expect Frankie to
be similar to Queen in terms of strength
his Bounty will also get significantly
higher than it currently is and there's
a simple reason for that the ancient
weapon pluton during the water 7 Arc we
learn Frankie has a connection to pluton
as he was once the holder of its
blueprints this is why a lot of fans
speculate that he'll be the one who
eventually finds or maybe even creates
pluton out of Thousand Sunny if this
happens his Bounty will Skyrocket
probably to
1,394 million berries if you're
wondering why I chose this specific
number for Frankie I'll explain it a bit
more when we get to usopp's Bounty God
Usopp if more than a th000 one piece
episodes or anything to go by Usopp most
likely isn't going to get any power up
in the traditional sense and he's going
to stay about as strong as he is right
now I mean that's kind of the point of
his character the moment he becomes
actually strong and brave his dream will
be accomplished and that's why Oda has
made sure to keep him the same old
coward no matter what he accomplished es
in the story however there's one
interesting potential power up Usopp
could unlock the conqueror's hockey okay
I know this sounds ridiculous but there
are some things hinting towards it you
all know how most of usopp's lives
eventually come true in the end and one
of his most recent lives during the woar
was having conqueror hockey this is why
a lot of fans think that it's a real
possibility he'll unlock it in the
upcoming arcs other than that another
one of his lies is that he'll lead an
army of 8,000 soldiers we know that usup
has a strong connection to all the
Giants he met throughout the story so
could it be that when when he finally
gets to the Giants Island El he'll
somehow become their leader this would
be really cool to see and would make the
great warrior Usopp feared around the
world now we know that Uso's bounties
often rhyme with Luffy each of their
starting bounties was 30 million berries
and Uso's current Bounty is 500 million
which was Luffy's bounty after dress
Rosa judging by this it's most likely
usopp's final Bounty will be exactly 1.5
billion Beres same as Luffy's previous
Bounty let's go back to Frankie's Bounty
for a bit as I still owe you an
explanation for that one I said his
Bounty is going to be exactly
1,394 million berries and that's because
Frankie's past two bounties have been
exactly 106 million lower than usopp's
since we estimated that usopp's final
Bounty will be 1 and2 billion it's only
logical that Frankie gets this odd
number there were still five more straw
hats left to cover and the next one is
Nico Robin the devil child Robin's fight
against black Maria and W was pretty
much her first proper fight since skypia
which was almost 20 years ago however
during this recent fight Robin did get
one huge power up demonio flour which
allows her to spawn a giant copy of her
upper body with giant Wings resembling a
devil now the question is can this new
form be considered a devil fruit
Awakening Hanahan noi is a really unique
devil fruit as it already allows Robin
to affect her surroundings by spotting
as many of her body parts as she wants
this is usually something only the users
of awaken devil fruits can do which is
why I think Robin's devil fruit is
already kind of Awakened and she won't
be getting any new devil fruit related
powerups
however when it comes to hockey she
definitely has a lot of room for
improvement and I think she'll
definitely Master it in the coming arcs
imagine her throwing thousands of
armament hockey slaps it would suit her
fighting cells so well so what about her
Bounty unfortunately there isn't any
numerical pattern we can follow when it
comes to Robin as her bounties are all
over the place but considering how
important she is due to her ability to
read poneglyphs her affiliation with the
Revolutionary Army as well as the fact
that she'll undoubtedly reach laugh
taale at some point I'd say around 1,9
150 million berries seems about right
for her jinbe the Knight of the sea
jinbe is a character that genuinely
doesn't need a power up what he needs is
a good opportunity to showcase his
abilities the only serious fight he had
in Destroy was against Who's Who and he
won that one pretty easily even pre-time
skip jimbe was portrayed to be Ace's
rival in terms of strength meaning that
right now he should be much stronger
than him but if I had to choose one
power up jimbe is going to unlock
towards the end of the series I'd say
with a lot of certainty that it'll be
conqueror hockey conqueror hockey is all
about willpower and jimbe definitely
showcased a lot of it during his epic
scene with big Mom showing he didn't
fear the emperor in the slightest
another possible power up for jimbe
would be a devil fruit but considering
how pretty much no fishermen have devil
fruit Powers This is highly unlikely
when it comes to bounties jimbe
currently has the third highest in the
crew right between zodo and Sanji
however if it helps Sanji fans feel any
better Jim's next Bounty probably won't
have that much of an increase putting
him around 2.2 billion million berries
black leg Sanji during wano Sanji proved
to be above Emperor Commander tier he's
probably comparable to someone like
Marco in terms of strength but
considering he's one of the main
fighters of the straw hats it's obvious
that he'll get even stronger the ifred
jamb he used in wano after Awakening his
genetic enhancements may not be the
power up we were all expecting but it
definitely is a cool one and was enough
to steamroll Queen until the end of the
series Sanji will get a better
understanding of his germa jeans and use
them to create an even hotter version of
diabl jamb since Sanji is a prince of
the jerma Kingdom it's possible that at
some point in the future he'll be able
to command all of jma's Special Forces
this will most likely happen in the
final war against the world government
and will earn Sanji a monstrous final
Bounty of 3.3 billion berries before we
cover the man himself Monkey D Luffy and
his ridiculous end of the story Bounty
let's first cover his right-hand man
Rona zodo the pirate Hunter zodo's
future powerups may be the most
straightforward out of all the straw
hats if he ever plans on surpassing
mihawk he'll need to figure out how to
turn his swords into black blades if I
had to guess I'd say the first sword
he'll turn black will be W ichimonji
simply because that's the sword zoto has
the strongest connection to as it was
previously wielded by his childhood
friend kinaa other than turning his
swords black he'll also find a supreme
grade blade and add it to his Arsenal I
mean Roger had one Whitebeard also had
one and of course mihawk sword yodu is
also a supreme grade blade it only makes
sense that zotto gets one to but which
one will he get yet well other than the
Supreme grade blades I just mentioned
the only known one is Shai KATU we have
no idea where this blade currently is
maybe that ball guy from the five Elders
has it whatever the case it's surely the
most befitting sword for Zoro
considering he already has one blade
from the kitetsu series other than the
sword related powerups Zoro may also
learn Advanced observation hockey at
some point as that's the only hockey
type he still hasn't unlocked since zodo
is expected to become the world's
strongest swordsman by the end of the
series his Bounty will have to be higher
than mihawk putting him at around 3.6
billion berries Straw Hat Luffy to be
completely honest it's hard to see Luffy
getting another major power up he's
already awakened a mythical Zan fruit
and has advanced Mastery of all three
forms of hockey he's also defeated kaido
who is considered the strongest creature
in the world in a one-on-one battle I
mean seriously what else can Luffy
possibly do to get any stronger than
this the only thing I can think of is
that he needs a bit better understanding
of gear five which would allow him to
waste less energy and stay transformed
for longer a lot of people still believe
Luffy will eventually unlock gear six
but that just makes no sense as he
himself said that gear five is his Peak
by the end of the story Luffy will
become king of the Pirates and the
strongest character in one piece even
stronger than Roger he's surely going to
defeat both Ayu and Blackbeard and if he
gets a match up against enu he'll defeat
them as well in the end Luffy will be in
a league of his own as for his Bounty
it's going to be exactly 5
b656 million berries this would make his
Bounty slightly higher than Rogers which
would make sense and it'll also work
really well with the name of his devil
fruit gumu means five and six after all
click on this video where we rank the 15
strongest swordsman in one piece